[Applause]
beirut was expecting tension but nothing
like this
for hours hezbollah fighters fought with
gunmen the civilians ran for cover
in a nearby school children were told to
lie face down for safety
it was a scene of masked men snipers
rocket-propelled grenades and bodies on
the street
the children were outside during recess
and we moved them immediately to safe
places we moved them to lower levels and
then we waited until the parents came to
take their children of course the
children were going through panic and
fear they cried and screamed
the lebanese armed forces moved in as
the casualties were taken out it
literally feels like a war zone here
in beirut today uh residents in areas
nearby where the clashes are happening
are
terrorized they are trapped between
armed gunmen on both sides
the violence broke out as hezbollah and
its closest political ally were marching
to protest against the judge who's
conducting an inquiry into last year's
beirut port explosion
there has still been no one held
accountable for the blast
lebanon has been in collapse for months
it is experiencing one of the worst
financial crises in history
fuel shortages mean people have to queue
for hours to fill up vehicles and jerry
cans
basic medicine is often hard to come by
and state electricity is rationed to an
hour or two a day leaving major cities
in almost total darkness come nightfall
this is a worrying moment for lebanon
the scenes of gun battles on the streets
of beirut
are reminiscent of the civil war of the
1970s and 80s lebanon is already
teetering on collapse it wouldn't take
much to tip it over the edge
the coming hours will be crucial
will the violence escalate all can't be
restored
lebanon's future is in the balance
alistar bunker sky news